this is sort of like the family portion
of the tour how's that going I mean you
were in Ottawa last yeah it's great I
mean it's you know obviously we're where
I'm from we're very far away from for
Mike's family so it's really nice when
we we have shows up here because I get
to say hi I think Mike was Mike's like I
got breakfast was so until I got lunch
with these people like I'm gonna run by
these people and say hi as though he's
been super busy like just making the
rounds saying hello everybody does it
make it a nerve-racking at all for you
and you know that there is like your
in-laws are watching like I know the
area that we have are like seats that we
hold so I cannot look in that area
because once I clock the in-laws like
it's over I suddenly become really
self-conscious and I'm like oh my gosh
like they're looking at me either
they're watching me so um that area I
make sure that I don't focus on any one
person that makes you so normal and so
like it'd be even when I get had my in
luck they get a little bit but yeah I
get it yeah yeah so you you had
mentioned when you were a TT Canada the
last time that you weren't sure how you
were gonna tour with the family and how
you were gonna make that all work how's
that transitioning it's good I mean
there's no rulebook or you know anything
to follow like you just kind of have to
figure things out as you go but we've
been really lucky just to be blessed
with a baby that can kind of go with the
flow you asked I have a three-year-old a
six year old and I'm not so sure so yeah
but that's amazing well it's kind of
like and you start him from the
beginning I mean from you know like he's
three months old he's been kind of
traveling on a tour bus so he's he's
kind of used to it I don't know if you
ever really get used to it but he does
he does as well as better than better
than I could have ever hoped I would
imagine you tours very family-oriented
with you know
everybody that works on it yeah that's
it nice for everyone yeah and I think I
think people enjoy seeing Isaiah running
around too because it's kind of like oh
they miss their kids and you know we we
definitely have lots of family that
comes to different different shows as we
go through because everybody's got
family someplace yeah sure
now your set is amazing we were just
talking not too long ago it's that
circle feeling that feeling that there's
a good seat no matter where you're yeah
were you really instrumental in kind of
designing and orchestrating how that was
going to look um once we kind of got in
there we started working with a
different like tour designer and he he
just had some incredible ideas and like
oh my gosh that all sounds great you
know and then once we started getting
into like order of things I'd kind of
start getting in there a little bit more
but I mean I don't know anything about
liked or lighting or any stuff anything
like that
that was definitely more let the experts
handle yeah and I'll help out where I
can and certain songs I'd be like I know
this color feels weird for this song
like can we change things around and but
it's it's a collaborative effort and
it's a lot of fun to put together
something like this so we definitely
wanted to make sure that everybody just
had a great could have a great
experience and they do and I mean in
your voice is just you know again when
we're out in the field in Vegas
listening to you you know you are you
you have one of the best voice voices
out there right now whether it's country
music whether it's whatever it is how do
you care for it on such a busy schedule
honestly I am - I'm I'm good I'm your
melasma in that department um I have
friends that you know or like I gotta go
do my warm-ups like yeah they've spent
an hour warming up and I've never really
had to do that I'm just like I know it's
just this is what I love to do
I'm just going to go have fun with it
it's just always there there's I unless
I'm sick which which does happen but I
feel like I'm also like loud so I can
kind of like power through it yeah it's
good though it is good I'm I'm I'm and
it's a muscle I like working out I like
it's literally as a muscle I'm like it's
just like the rest of me